aujourd'hui je vais vous parler d'un
truc intéressant on va se parler des
pixel 7 versus pixel 7 pro pour savoir
lequel acheter je vais vous dire en fait
c'est super intéressant pourquoi et bien
parce que les pixels pixel 7 pixel 7 Pro
reste un tarif contenu là où il y a
beaucoup de smartphone premium très
Premium qui augmente énormément et je
vais vous dire justement pourquoi à mon
avis le pixel 7 c'est vraiment le bon
plan le très bon smartphone vers lequel
il faut aller alors pour se faire on va
faire quoi on va venir détailler les
différences entre le pixel 7 d'un côté
le pixel 7 Pro de l'autre côté et vous
allez voir au final ça fait vraiment
venir vous aiguiller vraiment vraiment
allez bien on y va
première chose à venir voir ici
lorsqu'on parle de ces smartphones on va
commencer par parler un petit peu du
prix le pixel 7 d'un côté et on a le
pixel 7 Pro de l'autre côté le pixel 7
il est sorti au tarif de 649 euros 649
euros c'est-à-dire que on est dans un
smartphone premium haut de gamme mais un
tarif qui reste quand même malgré tout
contenu c'est beaucoup d'argent 149 €,
on est d'accord mais par rapport à ce
qui augmente à droite à gauche on voit
que ça reste très contenu c'est super
intéressant et pour 250 euros de plus
vous avez le modèle professionnel qui
lui est à 899 euros et je vous dis bien
c'est plus
250 euros c'est juste énorme il y a donc
une très grosse différence et pour
autant et c'est là où c'est super
intéressant le pixel 7 pro il reste un
tarif qui est hyper maîtrisé par rapport
à un Samsung Galaxy S2 ultra par rapport
à un iPhone 14 pro parce qu'on se parle
effectivement du modèle professionnel
qui est largement au-dessus des 1000
euros donc là on est quand même un petit
peu moins de 900 balles et si vous
voulez son petit frère on est à 650
euros donc il y a quand même un delta
qui est énorme de 250 balles et c'est
pourquoi pourquoi ce pixel 7 est
probablement le smartphone très haut de
gamme à venir acheter dans cette fin
d'année alors on va regarder un petit
peu le tronc commun et qu'est-ce qui
différencie ces deux smartphones alors
sur ces deux smartphones vous avez la
nouvelle puce de Google c'est la tensor
c'est la G2 qui marche avec sa puce de
sécurité c'est la Titan m2 bon alors je
vous le passe très rapidement mais ça en
fait vous l'avez sur les deux
smartphones donc vous n'avez absolument
aucune différence entre d'un côté le
modèle Pro et de l'autre côté le pixel 7
donc c'est exactement la même chose au
niveau de la performance donc dans les
deux cas vous allez avoir une puce qui
est vraiment dédiée pour vous ayez le
meilleur de l'expérience Google alors je
vous le fais très très rapidement mais
en fait le truc qui est intéressant je
sais pas si vous avez regardé mon test
depuis 7 Pro ça vous explique un petit
peu chez Google vous avez différents
usages qui vont pouvoir être fait au
travers des pixels vous avez ce qu'on
appellera le pixel only c'est toutes les
fonctionnalités que vous n'aurez que sur
les pixels pourquoi parce que vous avez
une puce dédiée qui est optimisée pour
avoir des fonctionnalités qu'on ne
retrouvera que sur les pixels et vous
avez ensuite ce qu'on appellera le pixel
first et les fonctionnalités qui
arrivent d'abord sur vos pixels et qui
arriveront ensuite sur d'autres
smartphones Android bah il se garde un
peu exc au début après le distribue mais
tout ce qui est pixel only on ne
retrouvera jamais ailleurs parce qu'il
faudrait la puce danceor G2 et c'est pas
le cas les autres smartphones vont avoir
des processeurs de Qualcomm des snaps
dragon vont avoir des médiathèque ils
vont avoir d'autres processeurs encore
bon voilà c'est vraiment ça qu'il faut
venir retenir ici c'est-à-dire que vous
avez une puce qui est dédiée pour avoir
vraiment faire du Google que du Google
et des choses qui sont optimisées pour
Google donc ça c'est vraiment le premier
truc alors ensuite il va y avoir une
petite différence par exemple côté
performance vous avez de la RAM sur le
pixel 16 vous avez 8 Go de RAM sur le
Pro vous avez 12 Go de RAM de vous à moi
8 Go de RAM déjà ça fait largement le
taf en plus c'est la même techno qu'on
va voir ici sur un smartphone et sur
l'autre c'est la Technodrome c'est de la
lpdr5 donc c'est exactement la même
chose en stockage vous avez quasiment la
même chose également 128 256 et 512 pour
modèle professionnel c'est la même
techno du fs3.0 donc on a un truc qui
marche très bien et puis de toute façon
j'ai Google en met quasiment tout dans
le Cloud beaucoup donc même si vous
allez avoir des photos ici sur vos
smartphones il y a pas vraiment de
différence donc en termes de performance
vous aurez la même chose d'un côté de
l'autre il y a une petite différence du
côté de la batterie côté batterie on va
être sur du 4355 milliampères heure sur
pixel 7 et sur le modèle Pro on est sur
un 5000 millions par heure donc
effectivement on va se dire qu'ici on
aura un peu plus sous le capot après il
y a un autre truc qu'il faut venir
connaitre ici et qui met aussi ça un
petit peu en perspective c'est la taille
de la dalle forcément au niveau de votre
écran puisque sur votre pixel 7 vous
avez un écran de 6,3 pouces et sur le
modèle professionnel vous avez du 6,7
pouces donc l'écran sera un peu plus
grand consommera un peu plus bon après
ça fait expliqué aussi cette différence
au niveau de la batterie mais il y a un
autre truc qui est très intéressant
c'est que sur le pixel 7 vous êtes sur
une résolution en full HD+ là vous
arrivez jusqu'en quad HD plus sur le
pixel 7 Pro très honnêtement sur
pixelset Pro vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous mettre en quad HD plus c'est un
avenir consommé davantage donc on va
aller de toute façon sur du Full HD plus
oui il y a pas d'intérêt vous mettez pas
là-dessus vous mettez ici sur du Full HD
vous allez venir économiser la batterie
de votre smartphone sur votre modèle
professionnel donc de toute façon c'est
pas la très grosse différence la vraie
grosse différence qu'on va avoir ici
c'est que sur le modèle Pro vous avez
une dalle ltpo qui vous permettra pas
retourne rafraîchissement variable qui
va aller jusqu’à 120 Hertz donc cette
façon totalement automatique alors que
sur le pixel 7 et bien vous ne l'avez
pas vous allez venir choisir votre
nombre d'images par seconde et c'est
juste ça vous venez ici vous venez dans
vos paramètres vous allez dans votre
écran vous allez sur Affichage fluide
vous voyez et ici vous arrivez
uniquement sur du 90 donc une petite
différence mais une fois de plus vu le
positionnement du smartphone vu ce qu'il
fait on se parle bien dans smartphone à
649 euros ça me dérange pas énormément
parce que vous avez ce tronc commun qui
est le même entre le pixel 7 et Pixel 7
Pro donc ça c'est pas très problématique
pour moi dans les deux cas on a une
dalle OLED ça c'est quand même vachement
bien donc vous allez profiter d'un bel
écran sur le pixel 7 et le pixel 7 Pro
bien évidemment vous en ferez un petit
peu moins et c'est vraiment ce qui va
venir justifier cette différence de prix
ici alors vous allez voir qu'il y a ça
mais il y a pas que ça et une fois de
plus je mets vraiment le doigt là-dessus
parce que on se parle bien d'une
différence de
250 euros il y a 250 euros c'est
beaucoup d'argent les finitions sont
exactement les mêmes on va avoir la même
qualité de fabrication d'un produit à
l'autre c'est la même gamme de façon
donc ici il y a pas vraiment grosse
différence ce design que vous gagnez
comme ça ou comme ça ça marchera très
très bien la différence c'est que sur le
pixel 7 vous avez cette couleur là qui
est unique et qui est vraiment
uniquement pour le pixel 7 ce pixel 7
Pro vous avez cette couleur là unique
sinon sur le pixel 7 vous avez donc
cette couleur là qui est très sympa vous
allez avoir un petit un petit gris ça et
vous avez la couleur noire donc bon très
honnêtement ici il y a pas vraiment de
différence exactement la même chose vous
allez voir exactement la même charge
d'un côté de l'autre et là où ça change
vraiment et là où ça devient aussi
extrêmement intéressant c'est sur toute
la partie photo que vous soyez sur le
pixel 7 ou le pixel 7 Pro vous allez
avoir la même chose un point de détail
près c'est-à-dire que vous allez avoir
une caméra grand angle dans votre caméra
principale qui est une 50 mégapixels
vous avez également d'un côté et l'autre
ultra grand angle de 12 mégapixels c'est
exactement la même chose et la
différence que vous allez avoir c'est
que ce modèle professionnel vous en avez
un peu plus vous avez un téléobjectif et
là on arrive sur un 48 mégapixels donc
la vraie différence elle se fait là
c'est à dire que sur le pixel 7 vous
avez un zoom numérique qui va aller
jusqu'en x 8 ça c'est un zoom numérique
je vous mets un N tandis que sur le
pixel 7 Pro vous avez un zoom optique x
5 donc ça c'est vraiment de l'optique et
vous allez jusqu'à un X 30 numérique
voilà la différence que vous avez au
niveau de la photo mais ce qu'il faut
savoir ici c'est que chez Google c'est
ce qu'on appellerait de la photographie
computationnelle alors ça veut dire quoi
sous ce nom un peu barbare ça veut dire
qu'en fait ce sont les algorithmes de
Google qui vont traiter et qui vont
venir améliorer le rendu photographique
alors déjà ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous avez un super capteur que j'ai
testé que j'aime beaucoup le 50
mégapixels donc que vous fassiez une
photo avec votre pixel 7 ou avec votre
pixel 7 Pro ça sera exactement la même
chose vous avez la même puce vous avez
le même capteur vous avez la même
optique et vous avez derrière toute
l'intelligence artificielle la
photographie computationnelle de Google
donc vous sortirez exactement les mêmes
photos et une fois de plus pour 250
balles d'écart vous n'aurez pas le
téléobjectif vous l'aurez uniquement sur
le modèle professionnel la question
c'est à 250 balles près est-ce que vous
pouvez vous passer d'un téléobjectif
tout en sachant que vous avez une super
caméra principale grand angle de 50
mégapixels et un ultra grand-angle qui
est bien aussi 12 mégapixels donc la
question elle va vraiment se poser là
comme ça en plus de ça dans les deux cas
vous pouvez venir filmer jusqu'en 4K à
60 images par seconde avec un mode
thématique qui est très bon qui marche
très très bien dans les deux cas vous
avez une sim plus une ime dans les deux
cas vous avez de l'ip68 dans les deux
cas vous avez du wifi 6e dans les deux
cas vous avez du NFC vous pouvez venir
caster bref vous avez ici à 649 € tout
ce qu'on attend d'un smartphone très
haut de gamme avec quelques petits
détails et ces quelques petits détails
il coûte 250 balles de différence avec
le modèle professionnel donc si pour
vous le fait de ne pas monter jusqu'à
120 Hertz c'est pas très grave avec une
dalle ltpo est bien c'est pas grave je
vous dis une fois de plus le quad HD ici
on s'en fout complètement le
téléobjectif je sais pas rapprocher vous
vous êtes pas forcément besoin
d'interlever objectif d'autant plus que
déjà le traitement qui est fait ici avec
un zoom numérique c'est quand même pas
mal alors vous allez venir faire un zoom
x 2 le X 8 franchement je vous le
recommande pas mais en fois deux déjà
vous pouvez commencer à venir chercher
des choses et sinon vous avez la même
performance vous avez une batterie qui
tiendra une bonne journée sans aucun
problème après ça dépend une fois de
plus de vous et de vos usages vous avez
du Corning Gorilla glace victus d'un
côté et de l'autre donc résistant des
haut-parleurs stéréo trois micro pour la
réduction de bruit lors de vos appels et
puis surtout vous avez un truc que je
vous ai pas remarqué ici qui est
exactement la même chose vous avez
Android 13 et ce qui est aussi très
intéressant et ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est ce que fait Google ici c'est à
dire que il pousse qu'on appelle des
drops features on se parle pas ici de
mise à jour de sécurité ça vous les avez
vous aurez toutes les mises à jour
d'Android 13 mais surtout les
dropsitures c'est quoi Google développe
de nouvelles fonctionnalités
régulièrement et tous les trois mois et
vous pousse des nouvelles
fonctionnalités ce qui fait que votre
smartphone est bien à un instant T il ne
savait pas faire certaines choses et
trois mois après il saura le faire alors
à tout mais ça arrive petit à petit il y
a plein de nouvelles fonctionnalités qui
sont arrivées qui étaient déjà très
intéressantes qu'on avait vu j'ai déjà
fait un live dessus pour vous en parler
sur les pixels 6 et Pixel 6 pro c'est
exactement le même fonctionnement qu'ils
ont ici donc en fait et c'est là où
c'est aussi super cool c'est à dire que
sur ce smartphone on se parle bien ici
du pixel 7 et pas du pixel 7 pro c'est
la raison pour laquelle je crois que
c'est vraiment le très bon plan de cette
fin d'année vous avez le dernier
smartphone de Google avec beaucoup de
performances qui est très bon en photo
qui est un écran de bonne qualité qui
n'ira pas aussi loin qu'un modèle
professionnel mais c'est normal mais
surtout un tarif 250 euros moins cher
649 euros c'est pourquoi vous avez un
smartphone aujourd'hui très haut de
gamme à 649 euros donc si vous voulez un
super smartphone qui fera super photo
très belle écran plein de
fonctionnalités très cool avec plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités qui arrivent
régulièrement pixel 7 pour moi il est
très bon après si vous voulez aller plus
loin en photo si vous voulez aller sur
120 Hertz si vous voulez une plus grosse
batterie et si vous voulez un tel
objectif vous prenez 250 € et vous venez
les rajouter mais aujourd'hui si vous
voulez un très bon smartphone n'arrive
plus maîtriser pixel 7 alors dites-moi
ce que vous en pensez dans les
commentaires est-ce que vous avez acheté
le pixel 7 et que ça c'est pro alors si
vous avez déjà un pixel si soit pixel 6
Pro ne le changez pas gardez-le et si
vous avez un smartphone plus ancien
comment ça vous posez la question parce
que je vous le dis une fois de plus
c'était la très bonne surprise qu'a fait
Google ici c'est déjà de garder des
tarifs maîtrisés sur le modèle Pro et
sur le pixel 7 et surtout d'arriver avec
un pixel 7 à 649 euros d'autant plus que
il y a un smartphone qui est aussi très
intéressant qui est sorti il y a pas
longtemps c'est le pixel 6a et le pixel
6a il est vendu chez Google à
459 euros ça veut dire 200 euros de
moins que le pixel 7 donc en fait ça
vient vraiment vous positionner ce pixel
7 un tarif très agressif pour que
beaucoup de personnes aillent
aujourd'hui chez Google dans l'univers
dans l'écosystème avec un pixel et un
pixel 7 dites moi ce que vous en pensez
moi je trouve ça très intéressant et
très malin et très bien vu de la part de
Google c'est aujourd'hui un des
smartphones à venir acheter en cette fin
d'année c'est pixel 7 voilà dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler de Take voilà je vous
embrasse bisous Ciao